So today I'm going to give you
your money's worth in the
sense that some of you might
be taking this class to see
whether you would want to take
another philosophy class at
some point in the future.
And though a lot of what we've
been doing in this class is
typical of what one would do in
a philosophy class, one of
the things of which we haven't
done that much is close
reading of extended passages
from texts.
And so what I want to do today
is to read through as a
group--which means I talk
and you listen, so it's
not really a group.
But read through with you all
out there smiling back at me,
one section of Aristotle's
Ethics, in particular Book two
Chapter four, to try to situate
for you the two
responses that we read for today
that both exemplify the
theme of the course.
So roughly the first quarter
to third of lecture will be
going through this passage
from Aristotle.
I'll put the text up for you and
I'll talk you through it.
And then what I want to do is to
bring out to you how it is
that the two articles we read
for today pick up on very
specific and very precise
portions of the
Aristotelian text.
So as I said, we're going
to be looking closely at
something in the book that
we've been reading from
Aristotle, The Nicomachean
Ethics.
In particular, we have heard
many times recitation of
Aristotle's claim that virtues
of character are acquired
through habituation.
That just as one becomes a
player of the harp by playing
the harp, so too one becomes
just by acting as the just one
does, brave by acting like
the brave one does.
But Aristotle himself realizes
that this cannot be the full
story and he begins his
discussion in Book two Chapter
four something that we've read
twice already in this
class--once a few weeks ago
and reread for Tuesday.
Aristotle remarks that someone
might be puzzled by what we
mean by saying that we become
just by doing just actions and
temperate by doing temperate
actions.
For one might suppose that if
we do just or temperate
actions we are thereby,
just or temperate.
Aristotle wants to correct a
possible misconception of what
it is that he's claiming.
In particular, he wants to point
out that although it is
a necessary condition on being
just and temperate that one do
just and temperate
actions, it's not
a sufficient condition.
That is, although it's a
requirement to be just and
temperate that you have to act
in the way that the just or
temperate person does, it's
not enough to do that.
You need some other things
in addition.
And what we're doing today is
refining the understanding
that we've gotten already.
We knew already from the
previous readings and lectures
that Aristotle says: in order to
be just you have to act as
the just one does and habituate
yourself to that
sort of action.
And now he's going to give us
some additional conditions on
justice, temperance and
the other virtues.
So he says, "for actions to be
done temperately or justly, it
does not suffice that
they themselves
have the right qualities.
Rather the agent must also be
in the right state when he
does them." Now what could
Aristotle mean by that?
What does he mean by saying
for an action to be done
justly, it does not suffice,
it's not sufficient, for the
action to have the
right qualities.
In addition, the agent has
to be in the right state
when he does it?
Well suppose I act in a
temperate fashion simply
because the resources required
for me to act in an
intemperate fashion
aren't available.
Suppose the reason that I
refrain from drinking the
chocolate milk that's typically
in my fridge is
because there's no chocolate
milk in my
fridge for me to drink.
Suppose the reason that I
refrain from going to a party
on Saturday night is because
there are no parties available
for me to go to.
I have in that case, says
Aristotle, acted as the
temperate person would.
But I haven't done so as
the result of being
in the right state.
Or I might, intending to give an
object to somebody to whom
it doesn't belong, mistakenly
return it to
its rightful owner.
If I do that, I return the
object to its rightful owner.
I act as the just
person would.
But I don't do so for
the right reason.
Aristotle wants to say that if
you're temperate only because
you don't have the opportunity
to act in an intemperate way,
but that if you had that
opportunity you would, and
that if you act as the just
person would not because
you're aiming to be just, but
only because you've got faulty
information, your activity
doesn't count as an instance
of the virtue with which
he is concerned.
In particular, Aristotle says
that there are three
conditions that you need to
satisfy for your just act to
count as a virtuously just act
or your temperate act to count
as a temperate act and so on.
First, you need to do the action
knowing that you're
doing something virtuous.
Second, you need to decide to do
the action exactly because
doing so is virtuous.
And third, you need to do so
from what he calls a "firm and
unchanging state." So the first
condition is that the
reason that you be in a
situation where you know what
act is the virtuous one.
The second is, you choose it
because it's the virtuous one.
And the third is that your
choice isn't a one off thing
which is happening in this
situation, but not in others.
But rather that your choice is
expressive of, indicative of,
arising from a state of
character that you have that
persists over time.
And I'll give some examples
in a minute.
Aristotle says in summation that
"actions are called just
or temperate when they are the
sort that a just or temperate
person would do" where the just
or temperate person is
not the one who merely does the
actions, but the one who
does them "in the way that the
just or temperate person does
them."
So the question that that leaves
us with is this: what
is the way that a just or
temperate or brave or
otherwise virtuous person
does those acts?
So let's run through it with the
example of bravery, how it
is that we might satisfy the
three Aristotelian conditions?
The first condition you recall
is that you have to do the
action knowingly.
So suppose I'm out there on
the battlefield and I know
that there are two groups
of soldiers--
the brave ones and the
cowardly ones.
And I am totally clear that I
have no interest whatsoever in
risking my life.
So I make the decision that my
plan is to do whatever the
cowardly soldiers do.
And I set myself up in such a
way that I put myself in the
middle of a group of people
whom I take to be cowardly
soldiers and I follow along
with what it is
that they're doing.
If it turns out that I have
mistakenly selected a group of
brave soldiers to imitate
rather than a group of
cowardly soldiers to imitate, I
will perform a behavior that
is the same behavior that the
brave person would, but I
won't perform it in the way
that the brave person did.
I thought that I was imitating
the cowardly soldiers, but
because I was mistaken about
who the brave ones were and
who the cowardly ones were, I
mistakenly imitated an action
that turned out to be brave.
Aristotle says: No credit.
No credit for virtuous action.
The second requirement is that
in addition to knowing which
action is the virtuous one and
which is the non-virtuous one,
I have to decide to
perform the action
because it's virtuous.
So suppose now I'm in
a similar situation.
I'm out on the battlefield.
I know which group is the
cowardly group and I know
which group is the brave group
and I decide because I want to
get a good reputation that
I will do as the
brave soldiers do.
So I'm knowingly performing an
act that is brave, but I'm not
performing the act that is brave
because it is brave,
because in so doing I will
express a virtue, because in
so doing I will bring to
fruition this ideal state that
Aristotle has emphasized
the importance of.
I'm doing it because I'm
interested in getting a medal.
interested in getting a good
reputation.
Aristotle says, even if I do the
right thing, even if I do
the right thing knowingly,
if I do it with the wrong
motivation in mind.
No credit.
Third, Aristotle says that in
order for an action to count
as an expression of virtue,
I not only have to do it
knowingly and for the right
reason, I have to do it in
such a way that it expresses a
characterological feature of
mine that extends over time.
So suppose that I just this once
decide to act brave for
the sake of being brave, even
though usually I tend to act
in a cowardly way.
Aristotle says even if I do it
knowingly, even if I do it
under the description brave act,
which I'm doing for its
own sake, if in so doing I don't
express a continuous
feature of my character that
leads me to do this typically
in circumstances requiring
bravery, no credit.
And in fact, Aristotle imposes
a fourth condition as well.
And that's fourth condition is
articulated in the opening
paragraph of Book two
Chapter three.
And it reads as follows, "We
must take someone's pleasure
or pain following on
his actions to be
a sign of his state.
If someone who abstains from
bodily pleasures enjoys the
abstinence, he is temperate.
If he's grieved, he
is intemperate.
If he stands firm against
terrifying situations and does
not find it painful, he is
brave. But if he finds it
painful he is cowardly."
So let's go back to our list.
In order for an action to
count as virtuous on Aristotle's
picture, you have
to do it knowing that it's
the virtuous act.
You have to do it because
it's the virtuous
act for its own sake.
You have to do it as an
expression or result of a
standing character feature that
you have. And you have to
do it with enjoyment.
You have to do it in such a way
that it doesn't feel to
you like it's an imposition
to act that way.
The brave person on Aristotle's
view is the person
who knowingly, for the sake of
being brave regularly, and
with pleasure acts as the
brave person does.
Now next Thursday, we will start
looking at an ethical
theory which challenges
one and two.
We're going to look at
an ethical theory,
consequentialism.
A particular version of it,
utilitarianism which says that
the moral worth of an act
doesn't depend in any way on
the knowledge or intentions of
the person performing the act.
The texts we read for today
consider respectively the
fourth and third condition.
So the text that we read from
Julia Annas asks the question,
what does it mean to satisfy
Aristotle's fourth condition?
What does it mean?
What does it feel like to be
an individual for whom the
performance of acts in
accordance with virtue is
something that one does
with enjoyment?
And the other text that we read
for today--the John Doris
text--calls into question
whether the idea that in order
for an act to be virtuous it
has to come from a firm and
unchanging state, presupposes
something faulty about human
psychology.
So the two texts that we're
reading for today actually
come straight out of a careful
understanding of what's going
on in Book two Chapter four
of The Nicomachean Ethics.
So I'm going to turn now to
those texts, but before I do
so I'm going to check that
everybody's clear on where we
got these four requirements on
what it is that they add to
the initial idea that we become
brave by doing brave
acts, just by doing just
acts, temperate by
doing temperate ones.
And that people are clear
how that came out of the
Aristotelian text that
we're looking at.
So questions before
we move on?
All right, so the paper that we
read by Julia Annas, who is
a scholar of ancient philosophy,
asks the following
question: what would it be like
to be an Aristotelian
good person?
That is, what is what's
sometimes called the
phenomenology--the what it feels
like from the inside--of
Aristotelian virtue?
Aristotle's told us that the
brave person is the one who
acts brave without feeling pain
at the bravery, who finds
it natural and pleasurable
to act as the
virtuous person does.
Annas' question is what
does that feel
like from the inside?
And her answer is now what it
feels like from the inside is
the kind of internal harmony
that we've been talking about
in many of the lectures in
this unit of the course.
"Exercising virtue is something
that in the virtuous
person involves a harmony of
feelings and deliberations,
rather than a feeling of
overcoming inclinations."
It is to be in a state
of internal harmony.
One's reflective commitments,
one's instincts, one's
apprehension of the world around
one, the patterns of
attention that one has to the
environment, all of those
comes together in such a way
that it doesn't even feel like
one is contemplating an
alternate possibility.
The brave person on the
Aristotelian picture doesn't
stand on the battlefield and
think, huh, I wonder what the
brave person should
do and what the
cowardly one should do.
Oh, that cowardly thing
is so tempting, but I
guess I'll avoid it.
The brave person stands on the
battlefield and--like the
person who has turned a
normative law into a
descriptive one from last
class--feels as if there's
nothing else to be done
then the brave action.
On the Aristotelian picture,
the just person, when faced
with the possibility of giving
back the right amount of
change or the wrong amount of
change in the transaction,
doesn't think to himself, hm,
I wonder if whether I ripped
off my partner I would
get caught.
Hm, I guess I wouldn't.
I suppose I'll do
the right thing.
The virtuous person on the
Aristotelian picture doesn't
even contemplate the alternative
activity.
And consequently, feels no
need to overcome the
alternative temptation.
There's not a feeling
of resisting a pull
in the other direction.
There's a feeling that the world
presents itself to you
with what is to be done, and
that you go on to do that.
Just as when you go over to
your friend's for dinner,
there is I take it, no thought
on your part what beautiful
silver candlesticks: should I
bring them home with me or
should I leave them here?
So too for the Aristotelian
virtuous one is that feeling
with respect to anything
that we might think
of as a moral dilemma.
Now Aristotle also has quite a
bit to say about what it's
like to be in a state where
these feelings come apart,
where they pull in different
directions.
And the selections that we're
going to read from Aristotle
for next Tuesday discuss
exactly that question.
What is it like to be somebody
who has to force themselves to
be virtuous?
Whose instincts run the
other direction?
But he's in a position and
need to ask that question
exactly because he'd already
told us in Book two what it is
like to be in this harmonious,
virtuous state.
Now Julia Annas' suggestion is
that we can give articulation
to this idea in a contemporary
scientific paradigm by drawing
on a particular idea from
positive psychology,
this idea of flow.
So Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi, a
Hungarian-born psychologist
has for the last 30 years or so
talked to people who excel
in some domain or other and
asked them what it feels like
when they are doing the activity
which they do so well
in a way that is completely
absorbing and engaging.
So he talks to composers and he
talks to rock climbers and
he talks to firefighters and he
talks to musicians and he
asks them what it feels like to
be in a state: an athletic
state, a musical state, a
creative state, a state of
absorption in effective
parenting, whatever it is that
you do and you do well
and you enjoy.
What does it feel like
to be in that state?
And what he says--as you should
know if you had the
chance to watch his TED talk--is
that it is when our
attention is deliberately
focused on what we are doing
that the action is most
experienced as effortless.
In a state of complete
absorption, we're attentive to
the subtle nuances of
the experience.
You're playing basketball and
the location of the hoop and
the ball and your hand and the
other players is just there
for you has as a single
apprehension.
You're engaged in an absorbing
chess game and you have a feel
for the location of the
pieces on the board.
You're engaged in a conversation
with someone you
love or someone you care for and
all of the nuances and all
of the subtleties of
that interaction
are apparent to you.
Now what Annas notices is that
there are two particular
features of flow experience that
are actually central to
the ancient
harmony-of-the-soul notion of virtue.
And the first is that flow
activity, activity in which
you are fully absorbed
is experienced as
what she calls autotelic.
She's actually there making
use of terminology that
Csikszentmihalyi himself uses.
Auto meaning self, telic
meaning end.
Something that is autotelic
is an end in itself.
It's not a means to an end.
It's something that has--
wow, I'm remembering something
from Plato's Republic, from
those opening pages from our
very first reading assignment.
It's something that
we experience as
having intrinsic value.
It's something that when we do
it, we're not thinking of it
merely as a means to
some other end.
We're thinking of it as
something that is enjoyable
for its own sake.
A painter who's painting
paintings thinking: "How much
am I going to be able to sell
this for on the market?" is
not at the time of painting
absorbed in
painting for its own sake.
An athlete who thinks about
their performance only in
terms of how many points it
will get for them or their
team won't become fully absorbed
in the activity.
It turns out that even for
things of instrumental value,
the most effective way to do
with them with excellence is
to become so absorbed in them
that they feel to us to be of
intrinsic worth.
And this give us, I think, a new
insight on that three-way
divide that we had in the
opening pages of Book Two of
Plato's Republic when we were
told that there are things
that are instrumentally
valuable, things that are
intrinsically valuable and
things that are both.
It gives us a way of
understanding how even for
things that are merely
instrumentally valuable, we
can get caught up in our
engagement with them in such a
way that they feel to us to
have intrinsic worth.
And this is of course, both
a virtue and a vice.
The most famous commodity with
merely instrumental value is
of course, money.
The bills in your pocket, I
hasten to tell you, are not
worth as pieces of paper
much more than a
fraction of a penny.
But they have instrumental
value within a system of
economic give and take.
But even within that system of
economic give and take, they
are only of instrumental value
because money for its own sake
isn't useful.
Money is useful because it
allows us to purchase other
things that are useful
for their own sake--
beautiful cars, beautiful foods,
time to spend with our
friends and family,
opportunities to visit parts
of the world.
All of those are things that
we can buy with money.
But money in itself is of only
instrumental utility.
Nonetheless, exactly the human
psychological function that
enables us to treat something
like making a shot in a
basketball game, which is of
course only of instrumental
value, as if it were of
intrinsic value--that allows
us to get caught up in
experience, that allows us to
have this experience of flow,
can be redeployed so that we
come to think that whoever dies
with the largest number
in their bank account has
somehow won a game whose point
values weren't arbitrary.
So there is--as is very often
the case--both an upside and a
downside to this fact about
human psychology: the fact
that we are capable of
experiencing things that might
not have intrinsic value
as if they did.
And in fact, experiencing things
in that way is one of
the most powerfully engaging
things that we can do.
Exactly because when all of
our energies are directed
towards the activity, we
lose ourselves in it.
There is a feeling--and
Csikszentmihalyi describes
this beautifully in the last
five minutes of the TED talk
that I sent you to.
There is this feeling of
complete absorption, a feeling
of unselfconsciousness, a
feeling of a breakdown between
the boundaries of the self and
the boundaries of the world.
You become part of the scene
with respect to which you're
experiencing the flow.
And indeed, the moment you let
self-consciousness reemerge,
the flow gets disrupted.
Any of you who has never played
a sport or a musical
instrument or been in a play or
given a lecture knows the
danger of stepping out of the
scene and listening to
yourself doing it, how
disruptive that can be of the
experience.
So Annas' suggestion is that
Aristotle's idea of virtue is
the idea that virtue
and the activity of
virtue should feel flow-like.
It should feel absorbing.
It should feel non-reflective.
It should feel that when you are
in the act of being brave
or just or temperate or
magnanimous or magnificent or
any of the other Aristotelian
virtues, that what you
experience at that moment is
a feeling that you're doing
something about which
there was no choice.
This is just the way the world
is--with respect to which you
feel there to be intrinsic
value.
And where you feel fully
absorbed and unselfconsciuos.
And Csikszentmihalyi goes on in
his more systematic work to
explain that the reason that
this occurs is because there
is profound match between your
skill level and the challenge
that the activity
brings with it.
When we are presented with a
task, which is not challenging
for us and with respect to which
we have low skill, we
experience what Csikszentmihalyi
calls apathy.
So if there's something that's
not very hard for me, but I'm
not very good at it, there's
going to be little motivation
to respond to that
with engagement.
If my skill level is low and
the task is a little bit
harder, I might feel worried
in the face of my
inability to do it.
And if my skill level is low
and the challenge level is
high, I might even
feel anxiety.
Moving over, if my skill level
is moderate and the activity
is of low challenge to
me, I'll experience
a feeling of boredom.
I won't find myself
engaged by it.
I'll find the situation
to be tedious.
If my skill level is medium and
the activity is of high
challenge, I might
feel aroused.
I might feel intrigued by it.
I might feel some motivation
to act in that way.
But the cases where we feel
the most excitement in the
world are the cases where we
have the coping strategies
that enable us to act
effectively as agents.
You'll recall that when we
read the material from
Jonathan Haidt for last class
and the class before, he
described an experiment that
was done on the floor of a
nursing home where the patients
were either given the
responsibility for caring for
the plants on the floor or
somebody else cared for the
plants on the floor.
And the happiness level of
those who were engaged in
productive activity
was much higher.
Skillful coping, being able to
be a force of agency in the
world is for human
beings one of the
primary sources of happiness.
And if we think back to what we
talked about a few classes
ago on the importance of early
childhood secure attachment,
one way of understanding what
secure attachment includes is
a feeling of agency
in the world.
If when you cry it causes your
caregiver to come to you and
satisfy your needs, you come
to feel yourself to be
effective as an agent.
And so when our skill level is
high, even if the challenge
level is low, we'll feel
performing the activity a
certain kind of relaxation.
Those of you who play bubble
pop games on your telephone
and are good at them are
presumably experiencing that.
Many times we have high skill
level with a low challenge
activity and it enables us to
feel that we're relaxing.
When we have high skill level
and a challenge that's medium
for us, we get this
thrill of control.
The idea that here's something
you're trying to do.
You have pretty good mastery
of it and it gives you this
feeling of efficacy.
And finally, we have one cell
unexposed in this matrix.
And that's the cell that asks us
what it's like when we have
both high skill level and
a challenging activity.
And it won't surprise you
to learn that that
is where flow falls.
So Annas' suggestion, drawing
on Csikszentmihalyi as a way
of understanding Aristotle, is
that what it is like to be a
virtuous being from the inside
is to be fully absorbed in an
activity that is in some sense
enormously challenging.
It involves scanning the world
in such a way that you
recognize what situations are
morally demanding and acting
skillfully, naturally,
effortlessly, happily in a
state of harmony, in a way that
conforms with what the
world demands of you.
And in so doing one is fully
absorbed in an activity which
feels to one to be of
intrinsic worth.
And where the feeling of one's
self as a distinct agent
disappears because of
the absorption.
So that's the first
of the articles
that we read for today.
One which says, here's a demand
which Aristotle makes,
here's a way of understanding
that demand in the vocabulary
of a contemporary work
of social psychology.
The second piece that
we read for today
does exactly the opposite.
John Doris, following a number
of other philosophers
including Gilbert Harman and
several others suggests that
contemporary social psychology
shows that it's circumstance
rather than character
that's the primary
determinant of action.
What determines how we act in
a situation says Doris, says
social psychology--that is,
Doris says social psychology
says--when we are in a situation
what determines our
action is not something stable
about our character, not
Aristotle's condition three
that it be a state that
persists over time, but
rather incidental
features of the situation.
And as a result Aristotelian
moral psychology in particular
in its third condition demands
that we commit what social
psychologists call the
fundamental attribution error.
In order to explain the
fundamental attribution error,
let me present you with the
study that serves as the
paradigm instance showing the
ways in which circumstance and
not character appear to
determine behavior.
And I present this study to you
both because it's central
to this literature, and because
our very class we read
a piece by one of its
authors, Batson.
And when we get to the
punishment section, we'll be
reading a piece by its other
author, John Darley.
So the Good Samaritan parable
as those of you raised in
Christian religious traditions
know, is a story that Jesus
tells in the book of Luke when
he is asked basically the
question which we've asked Plato
and Aristotle to answer
for us: How is it that I can
behave in the way that
morality demands?
And the story that Jesus
tells runs as follows.
"A certain man was going down
from Jerusalem to Jericho and
he fell among robbers who both
stripped him and beat him and
departed leaving
him half dead.
By chance a certain priest
was going down that way.
When he saw him, he passed
by on the other side.
In the same way, a Levite also
when he came to the place saw
him and passed by
the other side.
But a certain Samaritan as he
traveled came where he was
when he saw him, he was
moved with compassion.
Came to him, bound up his
wounds, pouring on oil and
wine." That's apparently a nice
thing to do to wounds.
"Set him on his own animal,
brought him to an inn, took
care of him." And the
story continues.
He gives the innkeeper money
to take care of the man.
And Jesus says to the person who
asked for a story, "this
too should you do."
So the story of the Good
Samaritan is a story that, if
you are thinking about it,
should lead you presumably to
recognize the virtue of helping
the stranger in need.
It should make it particularly
salient to you that among the
moral demands that the world
places on you is that if
somebody is lying injured along
the wayside, and you are
in a position to help them, then
it would be in keeping
with the demands of morality for
you to stop and lean down
and pour oil and wine onto his
wounds--or whatever the
contemporary analog
of that is.
So the study that Darley and
Batson did ran as follows.
They took a bunch of divinity
school students at Princeton--
young seminarians.
You can see them there in their
young seminarian outfits.
And it asked some of them to
prepare a sermon on the
parable of the Good Samaritan.
So these are divinity school
students, presumably people
who are committed to developing
moral character in
themselves.
And what they've been asked to
do is to prepare a sermon on
something that makes very, very
salient to them that if
you stumble upon somebody who
is in need of your help, you
should stop and help them.
And then what Batson and Darley
did is they told some
of these people that they were
in a great rush to get to the
other side of campus where
they needed to
deliver their lecture.
And some of them they
didn't tell this to.
And some of the seminarians had
been told to do the Good
Samaritan story and some of the
seminarians had been told
to prepare another story.
Now you might thank if the
hypothesis that what
determines behavior is character
were true that those
seminarians who had prepared a
lecture on the Good Samaritan
would be particularly likely to
recognize the moral needs
attaching to stumbling upon
somebody who was injured.
And that the question of whether
they were late or
early to give their lecture
would have no bearing.
Darley and Batson decided
to test this.
What they did is they had the
seminarians walk over towards
the lecture hall.
And on their way there was
somebody lying on the sidewalk
in need of their help.
Now, what was predictive of
whether the seminarians
stopped to help this man on the
wayside was not whether
they had prepared a story about
the Good Samaritan.
It was whether they were in a
rush to get to their lecture.
And those of them who were,
very often not only didn't
help the man, they stepped over
his body and rushed over
to the theater.
Now all of us have
experienced this.
If I'm in a rush to pick up my
kids and I have to pull over
because there's an ambulance
coming the other way, I feel
incredible annoyance.
Why?
Because I think, "oh that person
in the ambulance, they
deserve to die because I've got
to pick up my kids?" No,
it's because when our attention
is directed towards
an external goal, it is very
hard for us to be attentive to
the moral features
of a situation.
And it turns out, over and over
and over again that when
we're trying to decide what
led somebody to act in a
particular way, we have a
tendency to over-credit
features on their
character--dispositional
features--and under-credit
situational features--features
of the circumstance.
So we think be for example, that
whether or not-- this is
the opening case in Doris'
paper-- whether or not you're
likely to help somebody pick up
their papers when they drop
them depends upon a feature
of your character.
Are you a helpful person
or an unhelpful person?
But it looks like you can
manipulate whether people are
going to be willing to help
simply by letting them find a
dime in a phone booth.
(If you don't know what a phone
booth is, there's a
movie called The Matrix and they
have phone booths in it.)
Whether or not they find a dime
in the phone booth is
what determines whether
they help.
In the Good Samaritan study,
it's not whether they're
thinking about being
helpful--it's whether
they're in a rush.
In the Milgram experiments,
it's not about whether in
general they behave one way or
the other--it's whether they
find themselves in a
circumstance where a demand is
made of them.
In the Vietnam "moral luck"
cases, it's not that these
young men who went to Vietnam
and found themselves in a
circumstance had a character
that would lead them to act in
that way says this theory--it's
that they found
themselves in this
circumstance.
So says John Doris,
the Aristotelian
theory can't be right.
It presupposes a faulty picture
of human psychology.
It's 11:20 now.
At the beginning of next
lecture, I'll pick up again
with two results from social
psychology that challenge, in
certain ways, the claim that
Doris is making against
Aristotle, and then we'll
continue with our discussion
of Aristotle's counter side to
this--what we do in cases of
weakness of the will and what
strategies are available to us
if we don't satisfy Aristotle's
four conditions.